I watch this movie disconnect if you can
pull it up let's just start with this so
disconnect there's a story uh with the
actor what's his name Jason Jason okay
so he's a great actor phenomenal job but
this story is a story of a father uh uh
who is working doing what he's doing his
son in a class look at box office look
at box office 1.5 think about it and I'm
telling you every parent must watch this
movie right so you know this father's
got this kid he's got a daughter and a
son the son falls in love with a kid in
school girl in school and he tells
another guy he finds out but the guy
tells the bully of the school the bully
of the school creates a face a fake
Facebook profile with the girl that he
likes his picture on there and befriends
all the people in school thinking that
he is the girl then she reaches out to
him and meaning he acting as if it's her
reaches out to him saying hey thank you
for your help with some message like
that on Facebook so I didn't even know
you paid attention to me so of course I
pay attention to you and then he starts
flirting with him thinking it's her
um
eventually the bully says I'll show you
mine if you show me yours okay so he's
like really yes so the bully sends a
picture of some girls you know naked and
it's just a bottom nothing more right
and the guy's like oh my God says then
he sent this picture but he wants the
the the bully wants him to send a
picture with his face in it so he does
they take that picture the next day the
kid goes to school everybody's looking
at this kid laughing at him right he's
like why is everybody laughing and
everybody starts showing a picture
listen you send this message and the
bully out some you know exposes them
right so this kid is devastated doesn't
know what to do he's 12 years old
doesn't know how to handle this goes
home turns on heavy metal music they're
wondering why he's doing that he's
hanging himself in his room sister walks
and holds him before he kills himself
father comes and says what the hell is
going on he says finally they find out
the situation that goes to the other
dads and then anyways this story right
here it's based on a true story by the
way it's based on a true and it's
happening and there's multiple there are
multiple versions of this I tell you
what I've done this on my YouTube
channel have a seat with Chris Hansen in
a case where a young man
same thing happened to him
and the mom went to and Not only was
this an embarrassment at school it got
into different sites that was being
traded for child porn
it went on Twitter and was being
disseminated on Twitter they went to
Twitter and said take this down
Twitter didn't act pretty well for
months and months and months and months
and it's a subject of a civil lawsuit
claiming that Twitter was complicit in
the distribution of child pornography
this is real life stuff this happened
you look at the case down in in Naples
not far from here
a girl was a very popular tick tocker
started during the pandemic 13 14 15. a
guy becomes obsessed shows up at the
door with a shotgun blows open the door
the father's a retired lieutenant from
Jersey City PD fortunately had a pistol
shoots him dead stand your ground case
we didn't find out until just a month or
so ago that this was all involved in a
Twitter type thing and it turns out the
guy who was shot dead the stalker had
been in contact with other kids at her
school to get information about her see
this is stories like this that I mean
it's it's you I mean look it's all great
to be on social media you know it's a
part of the fabric of our society of our
lives and kids should be able to go out
and create accounts and be able to
express themselves it's all good but
it's got to be monitored and the thing
that drives me crazy guys is you see
these parents who are exploiting their
children not in this case I'm not
arguing that in the case in Naples but
in other cases and I've done stories on
this where parents are pimping out their
kids in these quote unquote family only
channels and and YouTube sometimes
doesn't crack down on this stuff
so they'll
limit monetization on a on a show that I
do exposing this stuff
but the young girl who's being exploited
that show is fine they monetize the the
heck out of it it's it's insane so what
what do you do your parent you're
listening to this okay we we've heard
many different things what are the
guidelines because there's a difference
between being too intrusive it's like
Dad leave me alone mom leave me alone
you know let me have my own life versus
absolutely you know you know these guys
are out there you know they're out there
well you have to look
when we talk about the drug problem
there's demand reduction we treat it as
an illness sometimes as opposed to a
crime there's no demand reduction
effectively for Predators so your best
defense is education and the discussion
you have with your children at home
there's one discussion when they first
get online and have a phone there are
adults out there who want to trick you
kids don't like to be tricked and as
they get older and as you allow them
access to different areas of the
internet you have to up that
conversation and be very straight up
with them and say look you don't want to
hear this from me
but I do this for a living I talk to
people who live in this world and and
it's dangerous if you don't apply these
rules
they used to say to us when we were
growing up don't talk to strangers good
advice then good advice today but the
problem is the stranger on Wednesday is
so adapted grooming your child right
that he's not a stranger on Saturday
and I read these transcripts when I go
back and do the podcast Predators I've
caught I go back in the cases that we've
already done and I immersed myself in
the transcripts the confrontation the
interview the stuff that didn't
necessarily make the show at the time
and you see this pattern of grooming and
this normalization of adult sex to
children and this conversation where
they try to relate to a child at a
child's level and it follows a pattern
and it's effective because it works it
works time and time again so if you
eliminate that you educate and you
prepare your child and you have the
conversation let's just have the
conversation and they have to feel
comfortable coming to you you're not
going to take away the internet I'm
saying do you have kids yeah mine are
grown I mean my kids my tools are in the
business let's just say let's just say
you're you have a 10 year old kid today
how to become a role play with us what's
the conversation you have a son or you
have a daughter how do you have the
conversation I'm going to let you
visit YouTube okay but I'm going to put
protections on this and you need to know
that there are people on YouTube who are
creating content who are making shows
that at first appear to be appropriate
for children cartoonish but they're not
they're intended to trick you so I'm
going to watch closely and monitor the
content that you view the shows you
watch on YouTube
and if I see anything
we're going to have a conversation
and if anybody ever comes to you
who you don't know in real life and
wants to be your friend you need to tell
me about it I'm not going to punish you
but you need to tell me because why
because there are people out there who
want to hurt kids it's a sad reality of
life
it's sad but it's true there are people
that's why we have police that's why we
have the FBI that's why God created
parents however you want to freeze it
with your belief system in your own home
I'm here to protect you I'm not here to
punish you and you need to tell me if
something light happens and if there is
a bad guy out there who tries to do
something with you we'll go after him
together now are you specifically saying
YouTube for a reason because I would
feel like Snapchat would be probably I
use it just yeah Snapchat I'm using that
as a tick tock Snapchat whatever it is
and the thing that that you really have
to be careful with when the kids get on
and play these interactive games because
somebody posing as a 13 year old in St
Louis could be a 55 year old in his
mother's basement wearing his underwear
surrounded by Pizza boxers trying to
trick kids
you create these images in a kid's mind
and they get it right but I'll tell you
this early on in the Predator
investigations I had a
a group of maybe a dozen 13 14 year olds
and I said show of hands
how many of you been have been
approached online by an adult and it
made you uncomfortable
99 oh wow how many of you told your
parents
two
so they just don't feel comfortable
telling their parents if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]